weddings funerals prison halloween tyler
perry's medea has seen them all but how
do all the medea films stack up against
each other keep watching to find out how
we've ranked them from worst to best
after the first medea halloween film was
a scary silly success boot 2 a medea
halloween was sort of a no-brainer
unfortunately those behind the script
also saw the film as a no-brainer medea
spends most of the film driving around
in her cadillac with things going awry
around her medea and company are being
chased by a mysterious figure that they
believe to be a ghost that's rumored to
haunt the lake as shenanigans ensue it's
revealed that it's all a hoax that
medea's nephew also played by perry has
put on in the hopes of teaching his
teenage daughter a lesson while
audiences might enjoy some of the jump
scares that mark the horror movie genre
the plot feels like a random occurrence
of events strung together with no real
reason most of the jokes in the sequel
don't land and as a result the film
earned three nominations at the 38th
golden raspberry awards it's safe to say
perhaps that one medea halloween film
was enough
perhaps the funniest situation madea has
ever found herself in jail has her past
finally catch up with her in the
television series meet the browns medea
was last seen in a high-speed chase from
the police that resulted in her being
pulled over and arrested instead of
heading directly to jail medea was
sentenced to anger management courses
which went about as smoothly as one
would expect for somebody with medea's
disposition this lady is out of control
she is i can't help her in this
continuation of the storyline medea's
case goes to trial and she is sentenced
to 10 years in prison choosing to treat
it as a vacation medea insists that
she's not afraid during her time in jail
medea is able to help some fellow
inmates heal and forgive those who have
wronged them ultimately medea's case is
overturned and she's released from
prison along with a few other wrongfully
accused women while the premise of medea
in jail feels ripe for comedic potential
the film pulls a friday the 13th part 8
jason takes manhattan and spends far too
little time where ticket buyers expect
the main character to go by the time she
finally gets to prison the movie is more
than halfway done it's no surprise that
audiences likely feeling they've been a
bit cheated have given the film such a
low rating
originally intended to be the final
medea story a medea family funeral
received such lackluster reviews that it
reportedly convinced perry to bring the
character back via netflix's medea
homecoming when a medea family funeral
was first announced audiences largely
assumed the title was implying it would
be about medea's funeral instead the
flick had medea planning a funeral while
simultaneously hiding the cause of the
deceased death from his widower since
the man died while having an affair with
his wife's friend as the madcap film
continues more cases of infidelity are
exposed while some funeral jokes land
the plot never brings anything new to
the table resulting in a pretty dull way
to give medea a send-off like any
funeral the film wasn't much fun to sit
through and left participants wishing it
had never happened
based on the play that introduced
audiences to the character in the first
place a movie version of bad feels like
a no-brainer nevertheless it took perry
a few films before he was able to
successfully adapt the story to the big
screen one of the most memorable medea
films i can do battle by myself has an
impressive cast with perry writing and
directing taraji p hinton as the star
and a supporting cast that includes mary
j blige gladys knight and adam rodriguez
while most other madea films are
light-hearted and fun i can do battle by
myself takes a serious tone leaving only
sprinkles of comedy strewn about the
story follows henson's april as she
struggles with her alcohol addiction a
troubled past and an abusive partner she
juggles all this while trying to take
care of a niece and two nephews who have
recently come into her life as a whole
this is one of perry's most compelling
films but the lack of medea screen time
might be why this film is rated so low
in the grand scheme of his canon while
henson is solid in her role she isn't
the leading lady that audiences probably
wanted to see
ranking a bit higher than its sequel is
the first medea halloween film boo of
medea halloween while it certainly
wasn't made to garner any awards season
buzz this fun mix of the medea brand
with seasonal laughs boasted quippy
banter outlandish gags and a general
sense of silliness that makes it an easy
watch showing audiences what it takes to
scare medea much of the film's humor is
in the contrast between her frank
no-nonsense attitude and these pesky
supernatural threats that keep getting
in her way seeing medea afraid of
something is a hoot and it's what makes
this film worth watching this is a
halloween flick content to be funny
rather than terrifying and it's all the
stronger because of that mentality faced
with ghosts zombies murders and her
least favorite threat of all frat boys
medea is determined to make it through
halloween while remaining the scariest
thing in her neighborhood
another flick adapted from one of
perry's plays family has medea
attempting to bring her incredibly
dysfunctional family together after
hearing the news that one family
member's health is failing unfortunately
said family is too busy fighting amongst
themselves over petty drama to hear the
news of shirley's cancer diagnosis when
shirley passes away before fixing her
relationship with her family medea steps
in and takes over for her telling the
family to take responsibility for their
choices and make amends with one another
before it's too late while i can do
battle by myself suffered from being
slightly too dramatic and serious
medea's big happy family exists in the
ideal medea balance between comedic and
dramatic tones despite the plot
revolving around a cancer diagnosis it
manages to have a good time with a few
eccentric characters and a well-balanced
tone of comedy antics to keep the film
from lagging hallelujah hallelujah
the first holiday film that perry put
medea in christmas led to the
aforementioned halloween movies and who
knows at this point perhaps medea could
become the new charlie brown but while
the halloween films tried to earn laughs
harry wanted to tug at heartstrings with
this christmas film which explores
questions of religion and how the
holiday's origins can be reconciled with
their modern trappings without ever
getting overly preachy the film softens
its blows with some good yuletide gags
medea is a comedic character after all
while the film reaches for a feel good
vibe it feels very low budget making it
feel at its worst moments like a
hallmark channel film but this also
makes it feel like more of a holiday
story since modern audiences have become
so accustomed to the trappings of that
genre signaling end of the year sugary
sweet stories of inspiration don't be
surprised if by the end it makes you
want to sit on medea's lap and give her
a holiday hug
according to imdb's rating medea's
witness protection and a medea christmas
are tied in audience appreciation and
it's not difficult to see why as witness
features perry's iconic character paired
with the comedic talents of eugene levy
from shit's creek the film's plot has a
wall street banker and his family being
forced to live with medea as a form of
witness protection from the mob absurd
naturally hopelessly high concept sure
but the execution is so breezy and fun
it will make you want to go along for
the ride medea and levy play well off
each other as the two families in the
film learn to coexist and better relate
to those around them levy is one of the
all-time great second bananas and his
straight face deliveries and always
entertaining eyebrow arches drive a
lighthearted story with a little
something in it for everyone ultimately
witness is a fun time with enough
feel-good moments to make it worth
watching
the second medea movie to be released
after the character became a household
name family reunion was a key component
in an early career move that perry
masterfully orchestrated impressively it
was launched without the benefit of
major studio advertising campaigns or
major stars in lead roles this film
follows the same early medea formula of
serious storylines mixed with humor
which have always given perry's films a
distinctly on hollywood feel an enduring
trait that really makes them stand out
among the piles of other movies that
attempt to tread that fine line this
time around medea has been tasked with
becoming the guardian of a rebellious
team it doesn't take long for medea to
whip her into shape all the while
planning a family reunion for her large
dysfunctional clan the film covers some
dark topics but has an overarching
message of standing up for yourself and
those nearest to you medea teaches the
characters in this film that they need
to be strong enough to save themselves
because no one else is going to do it
for them you just prove you can be
anything you want to be while reunion
may not be as funny as some of the other
medea films its message about
empowerment and finding the strength
within gives it perhaps the best
underlying message of the series plus it
has the acting support of cicely tyson
blair underwood and even civil rights
activist poet maya angelou
the movie that started it all diary of a
mad black woman was an out of left field
hit that hollywood never saw coming much
like my big fat greek wedding a few
years earlier the film was released with
minimal fanfare but it was equally
successful due to the fact that its
filmmakers wisely galvanized
underrepresented audiences churchgoers
looking for wholesome hollywood
entertainment and strategic early
screening audiences perry's debut
feature film diary introduced the medea
character but didn't make her a central
focus of the film as with medea's family
reunion or medea goes to jail the
character serves as a wise if eccentric
sage used to help others come to terms
with their situations and find the
strength to fight back diary of a mad
black woman did a good job at balancing
romantic aspects with the dramatic and
emotional ones its comedy however was
what set it apart who could forget medea
taking a chainsaw to a couch declaring
that half of everything in the house
belonged to granddaughter
but it's also amazing to consider the
way perry used this film to not only
earn his seat in hollywood as a power
player but launch a career in his own
cottage industry that is still going
strong two decades later
after funeral landed with a thud this
2022 entry had perry deciding to team up
with netflix for a film that would bring
back his iconic character it's the
highest ranked medea flick on imdb by
fans so clearly that was the right
decision while homecoming has plenty of
humor it is also fueled by a theme of
acceptance and understanding that makes
the film engaging and heartfelt praising
the film's breezy watchability one imdb
user says in their review it's silly and
over the top but it is entertaining and
makes me laugh i'm glad tyler perry
decided to bring her back right now the
world needs a little bit of mindless
entertainment and laughter check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]